[Music]
thank you
when you were here before
could have guessed that you were fine
you smell like a bagel
adult girls make me cry
[Music]
you float my old Turbo
in my Bountiful to pass
I wish I was special
you're so inspection
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I want a perfect toddler
I want a perfect wing
[Music]
I hope they don't notice
when I'm sniffing round
[Music]
is so special
these kids smell so special
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but I'm a crazy
[Music]
what the hell am I doing here
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
laughs
I know some of you are asking you know
is there going to be a softened ladder
with Crowder no when we return nope Tom
York is rolling over in his well he's
not but if he had a grave his googly
grave uh and uh by the way this is all
made possible instead of phoning it in
by joining uh mud club.com glad to be
with you yesterday we set records with
people off of YouTube on Rumble so head
over there there's a whole month free
right now on Rumble the extended show
what you usually Miss if you're not
about Club member just go to rumble and
you get to watch it for free also well
I'll I'll go through we have a lot to
get to today okay first off uh Dylan
Mulvaney is um uh I don't wanna hit the
YouTube dump button just yet but you can
guess we'll be talking about Dylan
Mulvaney dressing like a child one does
new study has come out the coffee is
racist Lindsey Graham of course wants to
start World War Three and uh the D.C
Deputy Mayor is a pervert and we're also
going to get into Donald Trump and
voters of color is the term voters of
color colored voters
the United colored voters fund you can
say United Negros college fund is still
around and where he's making gains and
we're also of course on Trump arrest
watch so there's a lot to get to Gerald
hey how are you sir I'm doing well sir
how are you I'm good I'm good I'm hoping
that everyone on YouTube if you're still
just migrate over to rumble where are
you on YouTube still just please please
migrate over to rumble especially today
yes uh because in third chair today and
he'll be broadcasting from the studio um
you know him uh you love him contribute
but not so controversial now like oh
cuddly like a cuddly teddy bear I hope
he's okay with me saying that you can
watch his show today at noon Eastern on
mad maxworld.tv because we can't share
the link for Infowars Alex Jones how are
you sir it's good to be here
congratulations on the fact that your
show went number one in the first day
that it launched that is a big deal to
pull those type of numbers I know some
of uh back when Joe Rogan was still on
YouTube some of his biggest consecutive
viewers was like when I was on Elon Musk
it would hit about 150 170 I think we're
calling those records so to have 170 200
000 consecutive viewers over on Rumble
uh is as big as it gets you know even on
places like YouTube when Biden gives a
live speech gets about 100 live viewers
yeah when Obama will have a lot of
speech you get about five thousand so I
mean this isn't just dominating
conservative media it's dominating media
and that's great because independent
populist pro-human speech is popular and
we have to celebrate it and that's why
your Victory is your listeners and
viewers Victory it's all of our victory
for Independent Media because you didn't
go along with the censorship when I was
having my head chopped off uh four and
five years ago like conservative the
rest of them and so that's why I really
saw your perspective when you came out
and said what you said because you have
to remember what those groups did
previously supporting uh the rollouts
the lockdowns the forced injections the
censorship all of it now they don't
support it because we've won politically
and the world's waking up yes uh but but
thank you Alex here we're yeah
[Laughter]
by the way because Alex Jones is here
and because I am here uh we have the
very the YouTube is on a 10 second delay
so if you see this at any point during
the show
[Music]
and you hear that music that means that
uh we can't run it on YouTube and it is
still available on Rumble so um migrate
over there so you don't miss anything
and of course Dave Landau not here we
have Alex Jones today but please go see
his show this weekend in Greenville
South Carolina March 24th 25th go to
greenvillecomedyzone.com one of the best
in the business and man if you see him
live it's a treat all right we have a
lot to get into here
um first off I guess a question of the
day this is foreshadowing what is your
favorite white supremacist brand of
coffee
[Laughter]
from afru what's that mean yeah I
thought it was an acronym it's not it's
oh it's afro okay yes they did the study
they did the study not to be confused
with afro pick that's an entirely
different nonprofit it's a C4 not a C3
uh but first I'm very curious I know I
know Mr Jones is champion at the video
uh here is a transgender and to the best
of our knowledge this is not a troll but
in today's world it's very hard to know
this is a transgender beautiful Brave
individual who identifies as
Hitler people are essentially calling me
every name under the sun because I had
the rice advert on my jacket
so I need to tell you guys a little
something about me and you can call me
crazy you can call me whatever you'd
like any name under the sun
but I'm very in tune with my past and my
past lives and lifetimes that I've lived
before this one my last life just so
happened to be a very Infamous one Adolf
hit her he often myself was one of the
first memories I had from that lifetime
it came to me when I was five in my
nightmares
so many other things throughout my life
have connected me to my past
and you can go say oh go get on your
meds again you Nutter I've been on so
many meds and none of them have changed
what I saw when I was five
well uh I guess salutes to mind Fury
mine fake comp that is I don't know if
it's real or not do you find it hard
Alex now with some of these you're like
is this a troll and then half the time
you find out it's not a troll well yes
they're so insane and it just it's it's
it's unbelievable but at the end of the
day it's mentally ill people trying to
get attention yeah and I'm I'm like that
so I'm like them I understand why they
do it yes you dress in your past life or
your goebbles was that what your past
life is not my past life I'm actually a
clone of Guardians
I identify as Joseph kerbals well you
know what happened to me when I was a
kid you have trouble sleeping and you
know because I went through gross first
so they thought I was having um you know
like leg cramps turns out I was Himmler
that's right wow
so you know look it happens to the best
of us and it also happens to us by the
way it's a live show Monday through
Thursday today this is going to be fun
I'm glad Alex is
his hair on mine
your wish is the internet's command I
guarantee you you guys can send it in uh
it's a live show Monday through Thursday
at 10 A.M Eastern notification don't
work on YouTube okay they do on Rumble
so Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern we have shows on Friday now of
course every Friday now mug club we have
Nick de Paulo we have specials coming
from Brian kalingen Brewer Mr gunzing
gear uh by the way this is so good
though I gotta say uh that uh the
incredible music bit you did at the
intro that documentary about the Pinot
president was incredible you guys got to
put that on Spotify it'll go to number
one it won't go to number one but it'll
be there
but I like you will existence correct
you're far too kind people they say hey
is Alex Jones far too kind I say yes
he's first no no listen this happened
with a lot of the uh Fan Music they've
made in mind they put a couple years ago
on Spotify and it would get like 10
million views and they'd take it down
yeah so so I mean I'm serious I I think
you guys should put an album out of it
we do we have an album on Spotify if
you're on Spotify you can go and
actually uh if you're subscribed to the
podcast go and listen to our album We Do
parody week in September I didn't know
that yeah we've done a lot of them it
takes a lot takes a lot of work I mean
you do parody week in September I I just
didn't know that it was on Spotify
that's good yeah well no see great crazy
Minds um
both of us it's okay yeah I can say
you're crazy because I'm crazy too we're
all a little bit nutty so yes it is of
course go to rumble one month free of
Michael that's what makes all of this
possible by the way it's what makes any
of this possible the parodies the
sketches the research all references are
available at letterscutter.com
well I guess no just hit the link it's a
Mad Max world
it's a mad maxworld.tv is and you're
broadcasting at noon yes do not visit
madmexworld.tv do not visit
madmexworld.tv
but you see what we're saying there
freaking psycho it's reverse
psychology you almost got me opposite
day sorry he did he almost got me I just
pause all right speaking of this uh and
again we're going to get to Coffee by
the way are you a big fan of Lindsey
Graham
I uh trick question I know the answer
you're not so
I didn't need a soliloquy the answer was
no
um I don't want to put words in your
mouth but I mean well I do have a crush
on him do you as a fellow gay man yes uh
I mean I would date him if he that's why
I'm mad at him is he asked him to date
me once and he said
he's more of a Rachel Levine guy exactly
yeah but ew there's could have been
separated at Birth in these Slimer
triplets so
let's get to uh have you seen it let's
bring that up if Alex Jones didn't see
it from yesterday's show on mug Club the
side by side of Rachel Levine and Slimer
it's it's uncanny but
um Dylan Mulvaney now you know Dylan
Mulvaney because you have to uh but
Dylan Mulvaney now and this is where I
think this is important uh because all
of these things are acceptable the left
will say well that's probably a troll
the Hitler thing well I don't think it's
any more absurd than Dil Mulvaney now uh
dressing up like a six-year-old girl
from a children's book and I'll give you
some historical context as to why this
is disturbing
[Music]
especially at Christmas time
um so now you can comment below please
do and hit the like button again it
helps the algorithm on YouTube because
people want to tell you that we're dead
uh if you think this is crossing a line
now this is not the first time that this
has happened and by the way in the past
that this has happened when it happened
it was treated as legitimate you may not
remember this but the media roasted all
the critics of this person Stefani
spelled Steph on knee uh this person
actually went after me a long time ago
on social media as well they identified
as a six-year-old girl and then it
turned out by the way that uh they were
a sex slave with the adoptive parents or
all types of sexual images which we're
not going to show to you you can find on
the internet but said I just identified
as a six year old girl and everyone said
hey hold on a second this was a man who
fathered children left his family you
know he can now identify every once so
long as she is happy turns out the
adoptive parents were doing weird sex
tricks with Steph on me so the writings
right right we can see that we can see
the tea leaves here yeah exactly and in
days past this would have been cause for
concern maybe do some investigation
check in on somebody and see if they're
okay mentally now it's like well yeah
that just I guess that's fine sure well
just would you like to come to the White
House imagine being Dylan Mulvaney's
doctor oh
what do you do it's like well your
testosterone levels are a little bit off
from uh for a woman uh and your BMI is a
little under just you know what here's a
prescription for whatever you want take
my pain
this is a main lining of blurring the
lines and it's a whole leftist movement
not just a few people that say they
identify as children so they didn't get
access to them I see articles every day
where quote transgender men get busted
just a few days ago in Kentucky uh doing
things with the babies and like it's a
dude that says they're a woman and now
it wants access to babies I mean and
then you look at these people forget
whether they want to be a woman or not
just if you were walking down the street
at night and saw a person that looked
like this they look like the Joker they
don't look like women they don't look
like men and so it's basically like hit
the clowns coming to Texas
this is why the suicide rate the
attempted suicide rate doesn't improve
statistically you can check all the
references we've always provided these
because they're not recognized uh really
as men or as women you cannot control
Society you can't force them to say oh
yeah it's just like uh it's just like
him it's just like Riley's just like
Andy any of the women who work here you
go all right I now have to walk on
eggshells because I don't know what's
going to happen next and well notice
it's the new religion though yes it's
literally a religion that you can't
criticize because it's so Preposterous
and and so even South Park would
criticize it five ten years ago now they
don't even do it so again if I wanted to
identify as a dolphin I don't hurt
anybody it's fine but I'm not really a
dolphin I can go have an artificial fin
put on my head and I can sit there and
say my name is flipper and go ER I'm too
hairy for a dolphin which you used to
swim in high school how did you do you
have to go for like a full-on sugar wax
because you got you know you got the
Robin Williams fairness going you know
what's happened to me as I got older I
just get hairier and hairier like a
Turkish man yes and uh and uh it's not a
good trade-off it's not a good trade-off
we start losing hair here and gaining it
on our back everywhere else I was about
to say it's the old joke you know you
lose it on the top of your head and all
of a sudden you go to your nose and your
ears yeah yeah that's why I'm grateful
for manscape so let's go through Dylan
to attest to that point Dylan Mulvaney I
would say not because this person is
trans Dylan Mulvaney the individual this
should be acceptable uh clearly not
mentally well right now if this were
anybody else you would say okay hold on
maybe there might need to be some
um some type of help some type of assist
assistance provided here let's look at
the evidence of this as a person who
clearly has been clamoring for attention
this is narcissism at its at its peak
that's still Mulvaney back in the day
totally normal
75 of being a girl and I've been
carrying around tampons and pads for the
past two months but I've actually never
opened one up let's do it with you I
thought the letter stood for small
medium and large based on the size of
your Barbie pouch but afterwards I know
it's actually the level of your flow
when I have extensions in I don't know
my name I don't know where I live I just
have no sign that you have problems and
I know that I look like I could steal a
husband but I want to promise you look
me in the eyes I want to promise you
that I would never do that to you okay I
am a girls girl hide your husbands
ladies oh my gosh
that's sanity yeah and when I what hold
on a second I don't know that that's a
side effect of a typical side effect of
putting in hair extensions I don't think
so forgetting your name or where you
live if someone turns on the microwave
you piss your pants forget where you are
for a second I don't think that's
typical with hair extensions I think it
usually just makes your hair longer yeah
no I mean I've got hair extensions and
that didn't cause that problem at all I
have hair extensions on my trap hair I
just I love you guys need to go with
little earbud pieces though because I
look like Princess Leia with these ones
oh no now that's another Photoshop yeah
that's the other hey comment below do
you like him looking like a Princess
Leia that's Stephanie uh we can merge
Stephanie and Alex Jones Princess Leia
uh and hit the rumble button smash that
if you're on Rumble oh we have a beauty
contest you and I and Stephanie who's
the more beautiful woman you're supposed
to be here tomorrow right yes done
I saw those wigs and things and it's
such a fashion I I'm thinking about I
actually lead a double life as a woman
my name is Alexis okay and I'd like to
Premiere it tomorrow a little late
a lot of beautiful women work here yes
there are so I gotta get it right here
for tomorrow
no no we can have them we do have a lot
of beautiful women who work here oh now
you're being politically correct they're
allowed to be part of the beauty pageant
as well
beauty pageant and they'll have to enter
against us and I'll be given the award
so it's politically correct who bet on
the third chair when Alex would uh go
off the rails
Yakuza won that one no it's fun isn't
this fun seeing Alex Jones have fun
that's great plus all the references are
available so you know that you're
getting the information correct okay
here's something else this is not a joke
uh I sound like Joe Biden when I'm
saying that Joe uh former vice president
uh according to an article from the
esteemed publication afru as previously
mentioned esteemed if you drink coffee
uh you're a racist and that's because
coffee has its roots according to afro
as far as I know this is not an acronym
uh colonialism it's rooted in
colonialism with aphro very confidently
stating uh the global coffee company was
created through colonialism the white
supremacist system under which European
countries invaded subjugated and
exploited the countries of black and
brown people now I know that sounds
absurd though we should have seen the
writing on the wall with the original
iteration Max Schmeling house that was
one that should have that's on us yes
that we missed it but the exception does
not prove the rule if you're listening
on audio that makes no sense now
if you drink specialty coffee you're an
even bigger racist hmm
see here's the thing we could find
common ground because if you drink
specialty coffee you're a hipster and
everyone wants to beat your ass but yes
in this case they try and say you're a
racist well you don't need to be racist
to be shunned from Community yeah and I
do drink specialty coffee oh yeah I got
the coffee company from Jeremy yeah it's
great stuff so uh here's what they write
the very acceptance of the term
specialty coffee
suggests that some coffee is somehow
Superior to others
an idea that is rooted in whiteness hey
hold on a second think of how racist
this is aphro the esteemed colleague
there I'm sure peer-reviewed uh that I'm
sure they have a control group here they
have they do they they conducted a
control group and the control group was
just so the idea that something
is superior to others is whiteness it's
white supremacy hold on a second there
are basketball players that are superior
for example LeBron James is superior to
everyone here pretty much everyone on
Earth with the exception of Michael
Jordan if you go back through history
just let's just throw some Chum in the
water because I know you guys are going
to argue about it by the way LeBron
Michael Jordan you comment below we're
not talking baseball so the idea that
something is superior is racist it
doesn't apply when there are clearly
examples of black people or Asian people
being Superior to your basic white
person for example land speed records
you cannot find a Polish or an Irishman
in the 100 meter dash they are all black
area one they are superior athletes if
you look at the top ten compared to the
white people who were running at that
point in time superiority is based on
performance unless you view it through
the lens of hold on a second it must be
superiority based on race which doesn't
even make sense with coffee none of this
makes sense it doesn't make sense to me
I read through the article a little bit
and I hate myself for having done so but
it did say that here's here's why
because on slave ships they brought
coffee over so that's one of the roots
and also when slaves obviously write
slavery bad we have to say that
apparently every single day but we
mention it they actually brewed and
served coffee so that's how it has its
roots in racism and I'm like well that's
pretty much every product on the planet
like I think you also served water yeah
to people
we've got to be in water now I'm pretty
sure you also served slaves to people
how about guys we know where this all
came from slavery was okay this is all
Liberation theology the Carnegie
endowment yes in the 1940s they said how
are we going to divide America and get
them to accept communism but communism
that corporations control where they're
above it but use it to basically
monopolize society and they said we're
going to create racial and cultural
divisions and Fishers at every level so
for someone that's not been brainwashed
this seems ridiculous but for young
people in high school in college they
actually believe that everything's
racist everything's evil everything's
out to get them they don't understand
that they're being programmed with a
Playbook by the real anti-humans that
want to divide in Congress yeah so this
all seems nonsensical but but they're
being funded with grants guaranteed all
these groups are to put out this
nonsense it's a Playbook they're not
idiots they're not whacked out leftists
this is a Playbook to screw people up no
you're right it's a lie and that's the
same thing when we talk about covet
people say oh they might have not
communicated no they lied to you also
something important to note by the way
coffee is a very important export in
many countries in Africa by the way
particularly like Ethiopia Kenya South
America obviously and if you want to
talk about the history of coffee and
slavery I don't know if you know this
but there was something called the
Boston Tea Harbor where uh tea party
sorry in the Boston Harbor where we
dumped tea into the water and decided to
switch to Coffee which actually was kind
of a good thing that the Tea Party
happened before they had switched to
coffee can you imagine the damage that
would have been done on a few cups of
Joe as opposed to that weekend they
switched over which then you know in the
United did have a civil war to end
slavery before that you were part of the
English colonies whatever they wanted T
is the same thing yeah people came to
the west and all the groups were here
killing each other Europeans were in
Europe killing each other the Native
Americans were here killing each other
the people in Asia when they're killing
each other the average were killing each
other humans are all the same we act the
same the same way over and over again
but yes it's true the westerners came
here for gold and silver and tobacco and
coffee and all these things and tomatoes
and potatoes none of that was in Europe
so so so and that's why we started the
trade out of the Middle East into Asia
to bring all those great spices over so
remember AOC about five years ago she
said we need to get rid of cauliflower
it's racist yeah because it's white and
folks if you think I'm joking she said
we need to I'm okay with that one though
I don't I don't like but that's my point
is it turns out it's from Africa I I
like cauliflower with cheese sauce and
stuff on it the point is yeah is that
channel in case he's doing they're
territorializing and making everything
where young kids hear this and go oh my
God it's a white vegetable it's evil I
mean this is mental illness folks yeah
well uh also uh cauliflower is probably
not good for you with cheese really well
it's good for you with cheese it's
probably not the cheese whiz it's not if
it's a 90 cheese it's like the salad
that I dump bacon into it's no longer
healthy all right so back to the topic
at hand so by the way Masters good luck
so that's racist too
actually there's still rules I believe
in the books in Maryland that you can
only serve slaves shellfish Crustaceans
uh maximum of three times a week because
it was slave food you know like lobster
crab because they're boats and uh I
don't know if it's still on the books
but I know it was in the 1990s so here's
another thing by the way this doesn't
just come from afru here's someone
making the same point but in a way that
is self-effacing that's friendly that
Bridges the Gap Shack I don't know if
you know this he actually talked about
turning up uh his nose at the idea of
coffee because he said black people
don't really drink coffee here you go so
you've had a lot of great business deals
one of your biggest business regrets
Starbucks Giant
so my my agent calls me up and he says
Howard Schultz wants to do business with
you and I'm like coffee
because growing up in my household never
seen a black person drink coffee so it
was my thought process that black people
didn't drink coffee well a big swing and
a missed there Shack but uh Magic
Johnson along with his uh very
successful movie theaters he did invest
he was the owner of over 100 Starbucks
locations which again just shows you
that hey black people are allowed to
have differing opinions differing
investment mindsets opportunities but it
looks like by the way Shaq may have
actually known a little bit better than
than magic meanwhile you know it's not
racist is a hundred thousand down a year
from fentanyl uh the school's all
basically failing war in the streets in
the meanwhile leftists are telling us
worry about coffee it's evil well sure
but here's the thing though there are
some companies yeah we do need to be
fair here there are some companies
coffee companies that surprise us that
surprise us that are incredibly racist
and we actually have exclusive footage
hootie who experiences in the office
made us aware of just how racist coffee
has become
of
[Music]
um
well that doesn't seem like it should be
a commercially available product no I
didn't know they had talking cups like
that no it's once you pop the racism
don't stop so God help you by the way if
you also want to drive to go get a
coffee because apparently driving in a
car perpetuates income inequality this
is from Salon among the poorest
Americans who cannot afford cars nearly
half of all their trips occur without
any form of motorized Transportation
while more than a quarter will occur
using Transit hold on a second hold on a
second don't you want people to not use
cars that's what I thought well that's
all 15-minute City stuff right that's
the other excuse to get rid of the cars
because if everybody can't have them you
can't have them right um so we have
coffee now now we have cars and by the
way they're saying the same thing that
we've said only they're they're decrying
it racist I've been saying living in big
cities is what left us want you to do
why because they want you poor they want
you dependent on government
transportation and they're saying look
at people who are poor they're dependent
on government Transportation right so
are you encouraging them to move out to
the suburbs are you encouraging them to
live autonomous self-sufficient rural
Lifestyles no you want them in those
cities and then about
environmental racism because they live
in big cities where there's uh they're
smog in the air then about the
fact that they don't have cars because
it must be racist hey guess what
everyone out there black red yellow
white if you follow our advice live out
somewhere where you have your own car
where hopeful you can grow your own food
or at least go to a grocery store and
not get uh not become the victim of a
knockout that's what that's what Thomas
Jefferson said he said the way to unify
the country and he envisioned it into
slavery he wanted to put in the first uh
Declaration of Independence and then the
Constitution but he was unable to get it
through but he envisioned everybody even
if you lived and worked in the city you
should have some type of farm outside
town because it created a Unity of
culture and a yeoman farmer system and
he said if the public ever got
domesticated by not knowing how to farm
and cut off from the land that we would
basically degenerate into what we are
now so it literally is a moral issue uh
to to to to to be tied to the land yeah
well even look at the model cities
program right we look at what happened
under Lyndon Johnson Detroit was Beacon
of Freedom they picked Detroit as the
model City they said hey we wanted to
launch this model City's first Central
urbanized planning what do we do
Detroit's the wealthiest city in the
country let's take credit for it and
destroyed it hey Alex I want to hear you
tell people to smash the rumble button
who are watching right now I want you to
crush that Rumble button right now like
you're punching the Deep state right in
the nose they can't stand it and
rumble's leading leading the fight when
it comes to allowing free speech and
then devastating uh the corporate Giants
so free speech and I'll give you the
guy's number there at Rumble because I
know you said you lost it yes yeah no
they're good people they really are
they're free speech people we have a
month of mug clever what are you guys
like
you knew this show was going to be this
way it's awesome
we have to draft them with these
otherwise it'll be a two-hour show we
when you'll be here tomorrow but I
skipped the Adderall today okay did you
I don't think you did I always do yeah
Thomas Jefferson once owned
Thomas Jefferson said if everybody has a
helicopter yes
but everybody needs a Blackhawk
the rural area that way that way I know
that's absolutely I'm not going to drive
two hours to this Ranch 30 minutes no
starting off in a helicopter yeah
absolutely all you need is I have a
million dollars the reason I was here in
a helicopter it's not my helicopter the
reason I was hearing a helicopter was
because the weather it was the roads
were closed remember that was the
blizzard yeah I know Democrats you're
gonna have to come here in a helicopter
I told you we could just have you next
week you're like don't worry Crowder I'm
already on my way it's like all right
it did happen if it did happen that way
I talked about it in my stand up I have
a whole I have like 10 minutes of Alex
Jones stories next time I'm in Austin uh
we can go over and people love it when I
say your name they go absolutely nuts uh
okay this one's teed up for you it's
t-ball okay Lindsey Graham
oh yeah so he was uh on The Daily Show
last night hosted by uh Al Franken for
those of you who don't uh remember Al
Franken uh this guy do you have it there
yeah just yeah that guy uh so he said
some really dumb things about Ukraine
and this is where you see the increasing
disconnect Not Just Between the Deep
State as Alex calls them or the
establishment if you want to call them
that not just Democrats but even
Republicans who claim to be your
representatives and the average American
conservative with our views on the
Ukraine which brings us to this week's
insane in the Ukraine
[Music]
come on
Alex thinks he's on an acid trip
no every time I see the zielinski clip
and then I know it's real and I found
even more stuff it's not bad that he's
in high heels and leather dancing
grabbing men's butts it's that the word
is there's a lot more than that going on
and so just like macron they've been
putting power because they're totally
compromised I miss the days when it was
just Dominic strauscom got a little
handsy exactly well and here's the deal
at least he's not groping small children
yes well yeah that's he's just grabbing
men's butts yeah exactly I mean look I'm
not even sure that's him and then I
don't even know if that's true it did
look like him so okay speaking uh to
Frank and Lindsey Graham and I want to
hear your opinions on this here
regarding Ukraine and Russian I
understand that it's more nuanced to use
a word that a lot of people use when
they want you know Lindsey Graham has a
crush on zielinski
okay so
a World War III Crush yes there you go
there you go because here's Lindsey
Graham thank you thank you for laying it
up for me advocating the United States
join the war in Ukraine let's find some
uh Common Ground uh for example uh
Ukraine we both believe that this is a
the vital interests
the Bold move cotton and he should be in
jail how about that I'm trying to be
helpful I think the ukrainians need
f-16s yesterday I think I would do more
on the military front but we're in it
together right I want to help the
administration where I can so here's
something that I know that Al is just
going to want to get into right so
Graham wants to send f-16s okay he wants
to do more militarily here's something
that you should know not saying this
would be why but Lockheed Martin the
maker of the F-16 is one of the top
donors to Lindsey Graham oh oops and of
course Graham has other justifications
for the unending uh support of Ukraine
which look can we all agree here like
this this is well I don't want to put
word Gmail as far as I'm concerned these
are two bags of crap fighting each other
Ukraine is not a Bastion of freedom and
democracy and certainly Russia I'm no
fan of Putin not a fan of either is that
is that a fair assessment's fair and
this was an entirely avoidable problem
yes a Slavic Civil War yeah yeah I mean
Russia actually started in Ukraine over
a thousand years ago it's a whole story
about how that happened then the Muslims
took over for a while all that was left
was the Moscow tribe they came and
kicked the Muslims out after 100 years
yeah became the big heroes that's the
founding of Russia is in Ukraine so yes
you've had the Catholic and the Orthodox
side for since then since the Liberation
battling for 800 years or so over who's
going to run it and it is an ancient
basically Crips versus Bloods right
exactly so so they're the same genetics
yes but they're fighting over color and
you can say that uh Putin and his
offensive maneuver and him attacking is
horrible but you can also identify that
you know what there's a certain
percentage of ukrainians who identify as
ethnic Russians in other words there are
some complications here that you may not
understand As Americans and I just don't
believe that we should be sending over
bodies or money it's not our war you
comment below and let me know what you
think of course Lindsay World War III
Graham that should be his new nickname
it has other justifications so let's go
through the claims here as to why
Lindsey Graham thinks we need to get
more engaged there's also a lot of irony
too yes yes and we'll get into that so
here's claim number one is that saving
Ukraine is equivalent to saving
democracy he's trying to destroy a
neighboring democracy he hates democracy
Putin and I will just say this to to
President Putin if you invade the
Ukraine you will destroy the ability of
future presidents to treat you in Russia
as normal you'll long for the good old
days of the Cold War because every
president in the future will pound you
in every Congress in the future will
pound you if you dismantle this
democracy so be careful what you wish
that's what I was going to say wishful
thinking big into pounding pounds yeah
pound you yes oh McCain yeah dang it my
my friends my friends
I'll pound my friends so
get in here hit on the desk bring it in
Lindsay get on the dash get on the desk
but not above my not above my shoulders
not about my shoulders pound you on the
desk you're hurting my legs wheelbarrow
wheelbarrow so I can do this I get it
just don't say oh you're not no it's
just we're talking about I don't care
whatever you can go watch go watch it on
Rumble because YouTube can piss off so
here's the truth Ukraine is hardly a
Bastion of democracy again all
references are publicly available at
ladderwithcrediter.com you can check the
references below they've outlawed all
political parties including ones that
are pro-war yeah they have taken over
all the TV all the radio all the media
unified it uh if anyone even criticizes
the war they're locked up in camps uh
and zielinski's now banned the oldest
church in Ukraine the Orthodox Church
there's a little bit more to that though
the Orthodox church and their ties with
Putin right it's all the same yeah yeah
but they also by the way with all of
that said Ukraine is rated as the second
most corrupt country in all of Europe
Russia's number one that's why I say let
them let's break off the pool cue and
let's have tryouts I don't care at this
point by the way the rankings are
determined by public sector corruption
so that includes bribery unlawful
unethical practices if you're talking
about money laundering this is something
that is well known it has been
documented by even the international
governing agencies who really really
want you to go to war for Ukraine so
saving uh Ukraine is saving democracy
not exactly not exactly and by the way
this is the country that wants you to
believe Hunter Biden is worth millions
of dollars a year
oh my word Charisma yeah here's another
Truth uh democracy uh really isn't the
main consideration when we're talking
about foreign policy here the U.S
doesn't have
the power to defend every Democratic
movement in the world nor should we by
the way we tried we failed over and over
in the Middle East you guys know that
that worked like a charm didn't it yeah
you can't find it Well that's what I was
going to say about the full clip because
before we went live uh your producer was
you know showing me some Eclipse we're
gonna be playing and I already seen the
clip but buddy Graham goes on to say you
can't just go and invade countries and
rewrite their borders and and put in new
governments that's that's you've got to
go to war with a country that does that
and I'm just thinking wow the U.S in the
last century is the champion of doing
that yeah and we sure maybe we had
reasons the point is
by his rules then the United States is
far worse than Russia yeah
yeah I don't know that I would agree
with because the United States doesn't
take over the land in other words I
would say proof positive the U.S isn't
just like like Russia would take over
Ukraine if they could the fact is Canada
couldn't stop us if they tried their
Mighty best we could take them over by
two o'clock today so yeah we kind of
have these proxy wars but then we
maintain interest in trading as opposed
to just actually taking over land
corporations take them over look I love
America and what's left of it I'm not
saying America is worse than Russia I'm
saying no the irony of his statement
that you can't just invade countries
right yes what are you doing oh my God
yeah no exactly now watch me Advocate uh
by proxy invading this he's usually
swinging by chandeliers attack attack
like did he found them in World War II
uh the US allied with the Soviets yeah
right and we keep allies like Saudi
Arabia to hedge against Iran sometimes
you Ally yourselves with bad people I
understand that the point is that the
point is it's not as simple as democracy
good everything else bad and certainly
not as you're applying it to Ukraine and
Russia where neither one really has
something like democracy and they both
have leadership that is incredibly bad
which you're not allowed to say in a lot
of places on YouTube right now this may
be fact checked as misinformation right
because it decided to get rid of non-pro
Ukraine those are the words not
anti-ukraine narratives right non-pro
Ukraine narrative so if you're on
YouTube head on over to rumble right now
head on over to rumble and of course
we're going to be going for another full
45 minutes or hour with Alex Jones free
mug Club all month lottery.com we can
flip them the bird as long as you join
but do not visit mad maxworld.tv right
mad maxwell.tv at noon Eastern yeah do
not do because you will not be there
you're not allowed to go to Mad Max
world you are not and you won't be there
[Laughter]
all right let's go on to their next
claim with Lindsey Graham uh claim
number two he says we have to stand up
to Ukraine now Alex uh in order to deter
China
if you believe pulling the plug on
Ukraine makes China less provocative you
should not be allowed to drive in South
Carolina
so China's watching you shouldn't be
allowed to drive in South Carolina Mr
cataracts in Chief
I love that that was the insult that
either you should you should not be
allowed to drive in South Carolina oh so
take away something else that we don't
want to do it makes me racist if I drive
we just covered this especially if I'm
drinking coffee
so here's the truth
our unlimited support and unwavering
support it actually hurts our ability to
deter China now again this is the idea
of short-term gains which supercharged
is China it unifies them with Russia it
forces them to do deals in oil and gas
at am with India blowing up the
Nordstrom only helped Russia increase
their overall sales prices and as you
pointed out almost all of our weapons
are now depleted right that's exactly
the point right so this is actually a
quote I believe from uh uh assistant
secretary of defense for strategy and
force development uh Albert Colby said
that if we could favorably end the war
quickly that would be great but what
realistic Prospect is there that sending
Ukraine some f-16s is not going to alter
that it's a massive war of attrition and
Russia is gearing up for a long war and
like you just said here's a really
uncomfortable truth right you've
galvanized sort of China to side with
Russia we talked about that we did a
whole hour segment not that long ago
with you and gingersnap so DG Pig's
there right now yeah absolutely right
now this very moment I don't know how to
do the time difference I I can't go
through the anguish of adding six
whatever the hell it is
supplying the Ukraine with weapons look
this is something that you need the
economy is not a zero-sum game right you
can build more pies you can't just build
more carriers you can't just build more
it's very expensive it depletes our
weapons stockpile so this was also
something Kobe uh commented on saying
arguing right now that we must defend
Taiwan by defending Ukraine strange
credulity it doesn't make much sense if
the war goes on continuing to sap the
United States resources and resolve as
China grows in strength in Asia the
argument will become increasingly absurd
so we've so far spent or committed more
than 100 because I don't know what spent
versus committed 113 billion give or
take a few billion to Ukraine we've also
committed an entire host of weapons yeah
and just to be clear this is just from
the fact sheet public and Alex you
probably are super familiar with this by
the state department assuming we trust
them
uh they we have given the Ukraine over
1600 Stinger missiles 8 500 Javelin
missiles 54 000 other anti-armor systems
and Munitions a hundred thousand rounds
of small arms ammunition 100 million
sorry oh my gosh I misreading I got some
zeros admonish me someone needs to
admonish 100 million
rounds that's almost as many as you have
in your Jefferson Farm and then hundreds
of thousands of various other artillery
does that sound about right as far as
depleting our military Alex well that's
it the United States is basically out of
ammo yeah
and Russia's running out too but as you
said they're gearing up they're digging
in yeah and the warhawks are just
licking their lips because as you said
this is going to be they're talking
about a trillion dollar defense budget
right wow yeah just on defense yeah and
we're depleted and there was a recent
grading that came out that said the
United States uh military preparedness
is that an all-time low as far as modern
well and this is what pisses me off the
conversation that we had Ginger Snap and
I it was a different conversation then
because if we could have ended this
thing early yes end it right immediately
Russia moves in and takes Ukraine
immediately get it taken care of if you
let it go on everything that Alex just
said happens right we deplete Munitions
we make sure that we don't have anything
to be able to fight a war but we also
push China into the arms of Russia
because these guys are enemies they're
not naturally bedfellows right and now
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
so these guys are doing business
together that only makes it worse
knowing that we're not going to put it
into this so we're going to drag it out
forever and if you want to go take
Taiwan it looks like now's the right
time to do it China yeah yeah it just
makes that Taiwan actually matters to
the United States more not saying that
we necessarily need to get into a war
but if we wanted to be prepared for
something that would affect the rest of
the world sorry not you we don't need
Ukraine 80 of the trade going through
the South China Sea yeah and if you
expand on that Xi Jinping is literally
there sizing up Russia and Putin's
commitment to watch his flank when they
move on Taiwan and the word is they can
move in the next few months yeah except
Xi Jinping got stuck in a tree trying to
get the uh the honeybees yes he did oh
you're gonna get a job and by the way if
you want an actual strategic plan it
would be better to look at something
like what governor Ron desenses and by
the way him and Donald Trump actually
agree a lot as far as it relates to
Ukraine this is one area where they
share quite a bit of commonality where
he said while the U.S has many vital
national interests securing our borders
addressing the crisis of Readiness with
our military achieving energy security
and Independence and checking the
economic cultural and military power of
the Chinese Communist Party becoming
further entangled in a territorial
dispute between Ukraine and Russia is
not one of them and uh he understands
obviously there are trade-offs and
Graham understands the Lockheed Martin
checks and this goes back to Alex when
we were talking about uh yeah I was on
your show we were talking about sort of
the issues here with uh why we went with
Rumble and please go over and if you
want to keep supporting what we do like
I said join my club it's a month free
you get to see if you like it if not you
can bounce
um is
we constantly Wonder right there there's
a lot of money in the conservative
Movement we know that there are plenty
of people there are a lot of
billionaires there are a lot of and by
the way I'm not saying a lot on their
heart is in the right place yeah but
then you look at the people who
represent you we talked yesterday about
section 230. we talked about senators
and congressmen and all this Grand
standing right they have all of these
Senate hearings and then nothing
actually gets done when we had control
of pretty much everything the courts the
house the White House nothing was done
with 230 you wonder why let me also ask
you this
I've never met a Lindsey Graham fan I've
never met a Mitt Romney fan I've never
met a John McCain fan I've never met a
Paul Ryan fan you're also hard-pressed
to find it McCarthy fan people say okay
maybe win some lose them but the point
is how are these people always in the
positions of greatest power within the
party and it completely disconnects with
what you the average American at home
actually believes how is that the
representative I have the answer it's
called straight party voting and they've
been there 10 20 30 40 years in the case
of uh you know the turtle Mitch
McConnell and and so it's just
institutionalized that nobody really
runs against him or they've got 50 times
the money if they have a primary
Challenger the corporate media blocks
them out and so in very rare cases we're
able to take them out with Trump despite
all his issues he was able to ride in on
the populist tea party wave that built
with Ron Paul and you know you and so
many others uh and myself countless
other promoting Freedom that's what
scares the Republican and Democrat
establishment is that what Trump wrote
in on is what could take over a party
and so we actually have a two-party
system again the Democrats the party uh
of globalism and communism and collapse
in the New World Order and the
Republican party is a mix of neocons uh
and Blue Bloods and the new populist
vein that's almost taken it over so
we're very very close to actually having
two parties again in this country and
that's why the power structure and the
unit party's so scared that's actually a
very good point we are close to having
two parties again because we'll say man
the two-party system it no we're not
living with a two-party system right now
we are absolutely not we really are in a
unit party system the two-party system
is certainly better than the
parliamentary system I come from Canada
where you can have prime minister
blackface get 30 something percent of
the vote but I hope you like your weed
as you sit in your 14-day quarantine in
a camp all right we have uh and by the
way show Alex you love them there in the
comments section whether you're on
rumble or you're on YouTube and let us
know um you know third chair is going to
be rotating uh who who else you want to
see in there we have a lot of people
coming in here it's always fun when Alex
is in studio do not go to Mad Max do not
what is it Mad Max dot TV it's mad
maxworld.tv and that's just the latest
URL because they block our URLs all the
time to try to try to share the evil
place you're not supposed to go at right
12 Eastern today yeah where you won't be
in Mad Max world.tv doesn't exist but
this is an important story here uh the
D.C Deputy Mayor John falcicio if I have
that right falsitio I don't care
resigned his post after facing quote
serious allegations of sexual harassment
according to axios the allegations were
not detailed thank God but involve
unwelcome advances uh in sexual contact
and uh this might sound like local news
but um we always think it's important to
cover this Behavior look this is this is
true but there's also the flip side of
that which is you don't know what
constitutes sexual misconduct and it
makes me it makes everyone nervous I
like you said we have beautiful women's
office I don't even look him in the eyes
man well you're also a married man but I
also don't look any woman in the eyes
period especially if they're white women
black women you can compliment say like
oh you have a beautiful uh beautiful
skin like oh thank you they give you
free stuff that's a great Point remember
a few years ago the Gillette commercials
where it shows like a guy saying hi to a
girl and other guy stops see don't talk
to women right they're trying to say men
can't talk to women but we can have drag
queen time with men scantily dressed
shaking their butts in front of little
kids yeah well see I mean I mean come on
hey well hold on a second
did you hear that yeah did you just call
him say say it again what I called him a
okay all right no you've got to go
we've all done
Gerald hired HR I'm sorry you can't talk
that way and we have women in the office
[Music]
so you can see there's mug Club expands
you really can't
say those kinds of things no no I can't
see why Sam at all well
specifically women don't react
positively to using as a derogatory term
their genitals oh my God you are the
worst I know who says it's derogatory
well you use the word as an insult so
using specifically something feminine as
a slur is actually weaponizing gender
language and it can be perceived as
sexist what oh oh so that it's it's
gendered that it's a gender problem it's
a gender thing Sam yes I'm sorry I
didn't realize it was a gender problem
that's not the problem we can solve we
can solve that because I didn't want to
Target just one gender if it's gender
yeah especially if it's targeting one
we'll do both oh
you're a
what that's gendered
face
[Music]
[Applause]
all right okay sorry guys jeez man it's
great you got HR like right there next
door I'm not a fan of it no I don't know
why I've hired it listen I was trying to
build an organization okay I'm the CEO
yeah well why don't we then actually
move the lawyer in here do you have the
meetings right in this room you would
spend five minutes with Sam from HR and
regret your statement you would yes and
he's the worst I think he's tough I
don't think he's a no he's not
he's not I am we're gonna have to go
back Alex be careful please we just got
lectured we're gonna have to have him go
to HR that's true all right I'm
wondering if we have we have time do we
want to start the segment of Donald
Trump and the voters of color is there
anything by the way going on out there
guys with the Donald Trump arrest you
know sometimes we're not here yeah it's
like the outside world is sectioned off
so we have to let there's a great five
in here it feels I like the studio you
kind of have to close off the world
right yeah and sometimes we're like if
something is happening you guys have to
let us know the air support well you
know what I do want to ask him kind of
his opinion on it what he thinks Alex
Jones yeah so Alex is like obviously I
we covered this yesterday right and we
were talking about I made the point
today to to Lane that it seems like he's
playing 4D chess and there's not a lot
of people on the planet that can like
out you for supposedly wanting to arrest
them and then keep you from arresting
them by doing it right it seems like
that's what he's done because they
haven't done anything and it seems like
they're kind of backing down do you
think that's what was going on or do you
think they were ever going to arrest him
in the first place yeah Alex what do you
think
I believe that they intend to indict him
today or tomorrow
but at the same time the feds years ago
before the sexual limitations ran out on
this campaign Finance issue of Stormy
Daniels didn't do it so the statute of
limitations is over by two years it's
all a fraud it's all a stunt but I think
that they've got the Soros D.A who's
being pushed to do it uh hoping that
some of the other criminal
investigations in D.C and in Georgia go
ahead if he breaks the ice
but yes Trump is like an idiot savant
and I don't mean that mean some things
he does early genius some things aren't
but yes him coming out when the Secret
Service was told and we're getting ready
he's going to be indicted as early as
next Tuesday he called him on it yeah he
criticized it and then I think some
higher up Democrats and people said look
it's going to make you more popular he's
going to get the nomination now he's
going to win by a landslide it's already
vaulted him up in polls like 15 20
points ahead of Santa's just since last
week and and so it's blown up their face
but I at the end of the day think
they're still going to be pighanded in
in either today or tomorrow or Wednesday
go ahead uh with the indictment uh but
it's still up in the air because I think
so much pressure is being put on that
D.A even by smarter Democrats that are
saying listen you are going to basically
energize uh Donald Trump for sure do you
think there will be protests if he's
indicted oh
well that's I've got an issue with Trump
on that and I'm not saying he didn't
have the right to say it I'm not saying
he's wrong to say it but but I would
have said it better we got set up on
January 6. we know that now a million
people came there a few hundred attacked
the police the police hit themselves
with tear gas we don't have the footage
that's how the first breach happened but
then they waved in the other folks and
have put you know almost a thousand of
them in jail it's an American gulag it's
absolutely terrible and then Trump says
take our country back protest uh if I
get indicted well you could see then how
some people will think take the country
back and then if some revocateurs do
something they can now point right at
Trump and say see he basically pushed
him to do this so it does look like he's
trying to use the public to push right
up to the edge and I think in this
Powder Keg volatile situation we're in
we don't need to be like Anthony just
tried to burn down the police station in
Atlanta two weeks ago right we don't
want to be like them out shooting people
at four-way stops so they want violence
because they're losing hearts and Minds
we don't want to be like Maxine Waters
saying go out and get violent we want to
be the opposite I get he's pissed I get
it's wrong someday there may be a 1776
issue where things are so bad we've got
to get physical but I think we should
exhaust all the remedies first and I
don't think if there is a violent
revolution it should be randomly
attacking police or Capitol Buildings of
course it should be you know how George
Washington would do it and I'm not
wargaming that here I'm just saying War
physical war is a very serious issue and
it shouldn't start in some Riot yeah
which I don't think he wanted but like
you're saying he didn't word it maybe
prudently there's one thing protest you
know protests make your voices heard
peacefully which he did by the way on
January 6th but this just being in a
written post it'll be easy he's got a
lot of power and it'll allow them to
plant provocateurs like Ray Epps again
yeah in their provocateur some hot heads
and so it's like listen if you're
filling up your tractor with gasoline
and it's your farm do you have a right
to smoke a cigarette while you're doing
it yeah but it's probably something you
shouldn't do right and so he basically
he's lighting up a cigarette while he's
playing with gasoline yeah in light of
January six like you said it's not it
obviously the events of January 6 like
you said a handful of people 100 people
a couple hundred people attacked the
capital it's not that it's how they used
it to make exactly it's how they used it
and why is he feeding into that
narrative right but of course his first
post had typos and stuff it's kind of
endearing that he was 10 o'clock at
night he'd had like 607 Big Macs right
and you know what half a half I think
half a container of uh
what's The Little Speed pills he's
always got on his desk
without nobody has every right to be
pissed he does is it right but yeah I
think we all know oh is he oh there's
all these photos of him in his office
like did you see the Sudafed bottles
everywhere is that uh ephedrine in
Sudafed yeah is that what it is I know
like in broncade and stuff for asthma
but I do know he has every right to be
pissed and I think like what you're
saying though the media will take this
and it doesn't matter in other words now
no matter what happens if there's an act
of violence at all they will blame it on
Donald Trump he should have added one
word peacefully yeah protest against
this judicial tyranny something like
that yeah no I agree with it because
there are legal remedies to this to take
care of this right and it is
grandstanding like the best possible
picture for him to win re-election is
Trump in Hancock if that picture they're
not going to do that no they're not
going to do a purple walk they can't do
a purple walk there's no way although
it'll be hilarious if he does an AOC in
like fakes just kidding a better crazy
oh yeah that's why there's that's
why their separation of powers we have a
federal system
people say oh you're for the federal
government no I'm federal system for
folks that don't know I just didn't go
to school it's three branches of
government you have state and federal
and that's why the Secret Service is its
own Branch the executive uh in in many
courts with a higher standing than a
county or a district attorney so they're
there in negotiations that he won't be
put in the handcuffs if they do demand
to put him in jail a couple days the
secret service is going to stay in the
jail cell with him yeah and if you ever
went to prison it's never happened
before they're talking about having to
create a whole Wing where where
basically the emperor stays right
because if you do that again any
prosecutor could take out a president
anytime they want yes okay now let's do
uh the Trump with voters of color we'll
do that uh unmuck which by the way is
free all months
can I go really crazy
so uh but I do want to leave people this
of course it is Mad Max World dot TV is
where Alex Jones will not be at noon
Eastern but you know and I will not be
hosting out of your studio and you will
not be coming on the show well that last
part I we will not drink a bottle of
whiskey on Earth okay
I don't know what's happening so
give me a second give me a second I do
want to I do want to end with this and
it is Mad Max World dot TV
um we're talking about January 6 guys
and before we go to temuka this is one
thing too I saw a lot of during our
absence I sat there and I grew
increasingly frustrated
um because I saw a lot of people acting
surprised with what happened the
revelations of January 6 on Tucker
Carlson let me be really clear about
something uh there were new angles of
security footage with January 6 and
Tucker Carlson but we on this show if
you watch the show within the first two
months knew what had actually happened
on January 6th you knew that the Q Anon
Shaman had been escorted in and said we
have to be peaceful we talked about that
when I see people out there and this is
something that really does uh tie into
why we are so happy and it feels like a
10 000 ton weight has been lifted off my
shoulders with Rumble is we did an
entire January 6th stream actually on
Rumble remember that one Gerald uh there
was the weather so the hearing got
canceled and we took a risk right we
said you know what this will be a low
watch stream because uh there is no
event going on right now we're not tying
into something that's very top typical
there is no actual hearing but you know
what we're going to do it anyway three
or four hour stream you can go and watch
it on YouTube in Florida so there's a
hurricane in Florida so they stopped it
we said screw it we're going to do it
anyway and we went through every single
detail that at that point was publicly
available all of which by the way is
basically it was retreading when you
look at what Tucker was talking about
not that there's anything wrong I like
Tucker's show I think he does a lot of
great work sure there were new angles
but the spirit of what actually happened
January 6th was not new seven people
were killed officers no then it was five
then it was Zero we knew that we knew
the only person shot was better we knew
that the Q Anon Shaman was someone who
was very likely touched and was escorted
in he was welcomed in by the Capitol
Police here's my issue is when you have
not just the left but every single
person on the right until Tucker Carlson
we were on break and I was champion at
the bit saying we didn't know how could
we know we follow this on such a
granular level we didn't know this about
January 6th then you have to ask the
question why didn't they no this is an
entertainment show and we knew and we
provided you all those references for
months really four years when people who
are whether it's the Lindsey Grahams or
whether it's some of the talking heads
out there tell you we didn't know these
are Revelations and you've known it for
a long time where you've accepted it as
fact you do have to ask yourself why why
are we continually represented by people
like Lindsey Graham Mitt Romney at this
point on my show last week so before you
go to mug I was wrapping this up in a
nice little but go ahead no I wanna I
wanna this is important okay and it's
not about kissing you and your crew's
ass it's or or saying how great you know
Infowars has been let's be honest about
this okay
when you came out against conservative
Inc I think in a very nice friendly way
but then proved your point later when
they were saying things that weren't
true
I defended you because you were one of
the only people I mean the only big
person
who defended me when I was getting the
platform it had me on the day after and
continued to after that before you
really didn't have me on much you really
came mad because you realize we're all
going to hang together hang separate and
then all those other people actually
supported it and then cheerleaded it and
then turned around and act like they're
not having contracts to control people
no if if they back free speech in the
past in the general area then I'd say
okay they can kind of have these
predatory uh contracts because that's
their business okay but you're you have
a right to say you think it's bad and I
know I'm bringing up old issues here but
here's what viewers and listeners need
to know of why this is such an important
show everything else is too serious they
put out the truth and hardcore
information but make it fun that's why
the show's so popular and expanding is
something we need in America and
worldwide to to promote Freedom you also
have to understand everybody that
promotes Liberty gets targeted that's
why most people roll over like so many
of the controlled conservative
opposition groups who by having Stephen
Crowder and myself and many others out
there on the front lines that don't
compromise we make it safe for them now
to cover all the stories we covered a
year ago two years ago three years ago
four years ago five years ago and so
it's not that hey you know we're the
originals and we're the best and we're
the Mavericks and you know we are the
top gun on the team so just remember
that it's it's about understanding that
the function that we serve and that you
have served by supporting us and I mean
you know Stephen and uh my show all of
it is the fact that we won't compromise
when the big next story comes out while
everybody else sticks their finger in
the air and you know sees what's safe
and gets permission from Big tech for
what they can do uh you know ask Mommy
for permission we're gonna go
immediately with what we believe is the
information now I'm right about 95 of
the time Crowder is so and it's a good
thing neurotic about checking everything
he's running about 99 of the time but
the issue is we're trying to tell the
truth we're trying to get it right and
we're trying to be independent all these
other groups operate like politicians or
like they want to be in Hollywood and
it's all about their career not about
our future and not having world war
three and securing our borders and
stopping the Fentanyl and stabilizing
the dollar and
stopping all this crime and defending
free speech so that's why this is a
revolutionary Act of support Mud Club
and Stephen Crowder and what rumble's
doing is beautiful and what Elon Musk is
doing is beautiful and so that's what
I'm saying support what Elon Musk is
doing support Stephen Crowder become a
subscriber tell your friends and family
become subscribers but whatever you do
don't visit madmaxworld.tv no you
absolutely should not certainly not a
new and I apprecision I didn't pay him a
dime to say that by the way but I also
want to leave you with this do not take
my word for it when I say we've been
talking about this for years go back and
check the references if someone is
telling you that they're providing you
with facts and never
having actually provided you with a
referenceable fact that you can use for
yourself
your antenna should go up and that's a
lot of people out there don't trust me
don't take my word for it because I
wouldn't that's why we provide all the
references for you and we are going to
continue with Alex Jones on my club free
all month lottery.com just head on over
to rumble right now if you're on Rumble
hit that button boom we're going to keep
going just right now piss off YouTube
thank you
[Music]